wieder so eine situation würden das
nicht 100 vorreiter genau etwas knapp
netz willkommen beim ein video jahr
möchte ich freue mich auch überhaupt
nicht ihr seht schon ich habe christian
dabei ja es ist lange her dass wir das
letzte video zusammen gemacht haben
bestimmt schon wieder drei monate also
jetzt eigentlich auch gut so aber ich
brauche halt einfach ein
ich freue mich natürlich sehr dass er
dabei ist
und zwar im titelsong gelesen was machen
wir heute vor allem namen erraten und
spezialisierung und zwar habe ich immer
meinen instanz vertraut er hat wieder
ein paar von euch herausgesucht ein paar
hübsche mädels ein paar attraktive boys
und hat einfach die mir bei ängsten bild
von euch geschickt und heute habe ich
niemals krank über den ich weiß nicht ob
ich schaffen werde aber ich würde sagen
es ist extrem schwer
kann man so sagen klar was mit einem
nichts geschehen ein einschlagen auf
jeden fall wird er gleich ein bild von
irgendwem verläuft und ich hab halt fünf
versuche um zu erraten diese person
heißt also wie du heißt vielleicht
schaut das ja gerade nicht du wirst du
darfst du das nicht tun hat wenn man
heute wir wollen gar nicht lang lagern
von sofort an ich würde sagen bei 15.000
gibt's die nächste erraten folge was
soll ich noch zu erwarten schreibt in
die kommentare
und ab und folgt natürlich verändern
snapshot um nichts zu verpassen wenn ich
die nächsten bilder brauchen von euch
ganz wichtig war aber kurz eingeblendet
fange mit der jungen dame wie könnte die
hessen ich würde am liebsten erste
fordert alten ich würde sagen die 16
aber weil man guttenberg werde ich jetzt
mehr hat sie nicht hin zugeschrieben
aber heute fünf versuche ich sage sie
halt sophie fast alter
wir waren nicht ich höre ich habe das
mit der geplanten schlecht
das remstal oft mal eben marin leben
muss gehen
madeleine echt furchtbar ich hab dir da
musst du schon mal drauf kommen ich
kannte matellia aldi von alix ist ja das
gleiche schon bisher schon war die
nächste junge dame denn ich habe erstmal
zwei damen für dich oh das ist schwer
die türkin oder so oder so man kann
schon sagen dass in deutschland also in
deutschland
laura lara lena mitglieder
das ist so schwer da muss irgendwie ein
bisschen helfen so viele versuche das
objektiv ist meine erste band wieder ein
thema
sind schwierige name aber viele er
meinte wenn du mein gerät ohne auf
meinen internet zu gucken ist eher was
also ich finde er sieht eigentlich aus
wien waren philipp pascal oder einen
timo tavares kein basta timo lemmer
dominik schwierigen namen im was
exotisches ein bisschen exotisch aber
blue fire nicht julian dann lust auf
englisch englische version so müssen von
julian julian richtig 150 einfache
brauche ich aus julien der sid aus dem
team und hatte einfach sowie tuning
genannte lex börsen ja ich werde mir
oder ich bin aber schon mega stolz auf
meinen ersten erraten und natürlich
immer in den kommentaren mit radlern
ganz wichtig so gemacht
daniela also ich wünsche mir sagen gar
nicht so schlecht aber nein also
angelika angelina nadine die zehn waren
manuela emanuela junge heißt euch darauf
kommen die viel wert sagte mitte die
sich aus sicht der emanuela man sagt
einfach so ich führte sofort sagen
angelika diese aus wie eine
anschließende besuch und hält was sein
ich zeige ihnen jetzt mal eine und er
muss mal schauen ob er das gerät ich sag
niemals so jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
wie alkohol wie ist doch ganz klar oder
es soll einfach an den aufwinden jessica
wird aber beständig klassiker heißen
oder nicht ich sagte mir immer noch
nicht erhalten es schneller zunahmen
soraya das gehört zur reihe junior seien
zu schlecht aus wenn schützlingen ich
hab jetzt schon älter was ich muss schon
länger machen auch nicht wenn ja
eigentlich auch jetzt bekommen wir
bilden also ich muß grad etwa sei echt
also die die musiken zum teil echt sehr
hübsche und attraktive mädchen noch zwei
versuche mehr einfach so hast du noch
sms damit se gibt es und er hat es doch
ich mache jetzt wir wollen heute noch
fertig wms und dann 2000 jahre später
nahm sie li na will ihn aber sind
abgeschrieben
deine will ihn lieben hey junge das aber
im film gesagt ja aber jedem blick
du kannst auch sony mit erst schreiben
hier in den nächsten jahren etwa 11 uhr
im wege waren zeigt mir die nächsten
attraktiven voller war kennt ihr noch
die kommt auch mein video ist also dass
sie schöne grüße als jetzt aber die jung
dort hätten menschen sagen okay ich
werde erst mal schätzen besitzt und
sarah sophia loren julia julia julia ich
würde sagen könnte also durchaus mit
julia werden falsch juli junger mann
sagt joana oder johanna situation würden
wir denken dass man nicht 100 vorreiter
ich würde sagen das reicht erst mal
genug geraten sie heute mein kopf das
war genug konzentration für heute ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen lassen nach
oben dabei sind nicht papst hat auch
gerne christian bei instagram
vorbeigehen allem christiane chr es ohne
ii das ist cool in der jugend heutzutage
wir sehen uns übermorgen wieder haut
rein folgt er auf jeden fall bands ans
netz
und falls noch was einst max